[Musica]
esterno notte una strada buia
una donna
sola
indossa minigonna maglietta scollata
tacchi a spillo
prendete queste immagine e mettetela da
parte ci servirà fra poco per capire
come attraverso le parole si possa
condizionare il nostro modo di vedere le
cose il nostro modo di pensare
il nostro cervello funziona così associa
a ogni parola un'immagine se dico mano
pensiamo a questo a una mano Poi però
nel corso del tempo a ogni parola sono
stati appiccicati
altri significati Facciamo una prova vi
chiedo di pensare alla parola che
rappresenti per voi maggiormente
La Battaglia per i diritti delle donne
A me viene in mente la parola
femminismo ma femminismo è una parola
che al solo pronunciarla genera timore
perché evoca immagini di donne abbrutite
dalla battaglia di donne che odiano gli
uomini lo slogan degli anni 70 tremate
le streghe son tornate
le streghe
paura
femminismo è una parola che è stata
strumentalizzata con l'obiettivo di
togliere la potenza che invece porta con
sé che è la potenza
dell'uguaglianza sentite che bella che è
questa parola ce la segniamo
Iniziamo da voi però vi faccio qualche
domanda Fatemi divertire un po' credi
che le persone dovrebbero avere lo
stesso stipendio se fanno lo stesso
lavoro
credi che le donne non siano oggetti o
possedimenti dell'uomo e pertanto che
lui non debba controllare
credi che sia la donna a dover avere il
controllo del proprio corpo e decidere
in autonomia se e quando avere un figlio
credi che i lavori domestici e
l'accudimento di figli e genitori
anziani
debba essere diviso in modo uguale fra
uomo e donna
sinceri eh vi vedo
credi che gli uomini possano piangere ed
esprimere la propria sensibilità
liberamente
credi che lo studio sia una cosa
importante che non ci siano materie in
cui gli uomini sono più portati delle
ragazze per natura
bene Abbiamo finito Se avete risposto sì
alla maggior parte di queste domande
siete potenziali femministi o femministe
il faro del femminismo oggi è
l'uguaglianza perché non esiste una sola
forma di oppressione
Io l'ho capito attraverso il mio lavoro
e ve lo spiego così
il più privilegiato è il maschio bianco
caucasico etero cisgender normoabile e
io che ho tutte queste caratteristiche
ma sono una donna sono meno privilegiata
di lui ci siamo fin qui poi per ora ho
raccontato la storia di donne nere
lesbiche trans e loro erano meno
privilegiate di me Poi ho incontrato
donne negli angoli più remoti del
pianeta come in uno Slam lungo la
ferrovia di Calcutta e quelle donne
erano anche diversamente abili in un
luogo come l'India in cui il sistema
delle casse e la religione induista
perpetrano l'idea che in questa vita si
scontino le colpe delle vite precedenti
per quelle donne di privilegi non si può
parlare
in Occidente una forte accelerazione
alla presa di coscienza di milioni di
donne la rappresentato il movimento del
mito da quando quell'hashtag è stato
lanciato era il 2017
in tantissimi hanno cominciato a
realizzare che quello che avevano
vissuto magari anche molti anni prima
era stata una violenza Ma che non
avevano avuto gli strumenti per
decodificarla e quindi per denunciarla
Ho già sentito mille volte le parole
impossibile che una donna abbia subito
violenza e non se ne sia resa conto
e invece è proprio quello che succede e
Tutto parte dal fatto che viviamo in una
società che è talmente permeata dalla
violenza contro le donne che giustifica
i comportamenti predatori degli uomini
di normalizza e criminalizza stigmatizza
le donne che invece di quei
comportamenti sono vittime e così le
donne si sentono talmente in colpa
che finiscono per non denunciare
ve lo spiego meglio
quella che vedete è la piramide della
cultura dello stupro
alla base trovate gli atteggiamenti
sessisti le battute da spogliatoio gli
scherzi sullo stupro è il momento di
prendere l'immagine iniziale la donna
sola la strada buia la minigonna e
tacchi a spillo
succede quello che immaginate
che parole vi vengono in mente
se l'è cercata
quante volte le avrete sentite magari
pensate dette anche voi perché viviamo
in una società che normalizza la
violenza sulle donne a partire dalle
parole se l'è cercata
cosa capite
così guardando questa immagine
che c'è una parte della società che è
meno libera dell'altra che ha meno
diritti diritti Libertà altre parole da
sottolineare
ognuno fa i conti con la limitazione di
questa libertà
in maniera diversa i momenti diversi a
livelli diversi ma tocca a tutte presto
tardi
io ero molto piccola mi piaceva giocare
con le macchinine con i robot il mio
nomignolo in famiglia era mazzinghina in
onore del Grande Mazinga
e sono stata fortunata perché ho avuto
genitori illuminati che non mi hanno mai
detto Questi sono giochi da maschio mi
hanno sempre educata all'uguaglianza mi
hanno sempre lasciata libera di
scegliere cosa fare della mia vita
ben presto però ho dovuto rendermi conto
che io ero meno uguale dei miei amici
maschi
Stavo giocando sotto casa dei miei nonni
e c'era questo ragazzo molto più grande
di me
ero lì non mi ero neanche resa conto di
essere rimasta da sola ai giochi da
bambina
e me lo ritrovai davanti all'improvviso
mi fermo
Mi disse di alzarmi la gonna
e di fargli vedere le mutandine
io ero paralizzata dalla paura
quelle parole per me risuonarono
come un ordine continuavo a guardare il
balcone di mia nonna che era proprio lì
sopra quel giardinetto e mia nonna si
affacciava sempre per controllare dove
fossi
ma mia nonna in quel momento non si
affacciò
non finì lì
perché mi chiese anche di spostarmi le
mutandine
io Lo feci poi
non so come
trova il coraggio di scappare
vi potete immaginare come si senta
sporca colpevole una bambina di 6 anni
che non sa niente del mondo non sa
niente della sessualità che pensa di
essere come i suoi amici maschi mi
sentivo in colpa mi vergognavo perché
pensavo di essere stata io ad aver
provocato quella reazione perché quel
ragazzo con i miei amici non si era mai
comportato così ma io ero diversa
era una femmina anche se ero solo una
bambina
questa sensazione me la sono portata
dentro per tanto tempo l'ho raccontato a
pochissime persone finora neanche i miei
genitori
non volevo che fossero tristi
e ho sbagliato
bambine bambini ragazze e ragazzi usate
le parole parlate con i vostri genitori
e con gli adulti di riferimento e anche
per questo che ho deciso di raccontare
qui questa storia perché mi ci sono
voluti anni per capire che quella che
avevo vissuto era una violenza per
elaborarla
ma ho smesso di vergognarmi ho smesso di
vergognarmi per una colpa che non è mia
non lo è mai stata
non è colpa di una donna nascere donna
Ora però Arriva la parte bella della
storia eh perché da quel momento ho
iniziato a ribellarmi e non ho più
smesso mi ribellavo quando mi dicevano
che mi dovevo vestire in maniera più
femminile da allora avevo deciso di
indossare solo tute da ginnastica oppure
che fare motocross
era una cosa da maschi mi dicevano Sei
una femminista
A me quella parola un po' spaventava
perché mi venivano in mente le donne che
odiano gli uomini ha brutite dalla
battaglia e le streghe
all'epoca mi facevano paura Poi però se
ho una certezza nella vita è che non
sono una donna che odia gli uomini anzi
Casomai Il problema è stato il contrario
che li ho amati troppo finché non ho
incontrato il mio compagno
e non mi sento una donna abbrutita dalla
battaglia e ho smesso anche di aver
paura delle streghe
ma forse perché sono diventata una
strega anch'io
cosa rispondevo rispondevo io so
semplicemente che io e te siamo uguali
anche se apparteniamo due generi diversi
solo che non veniamo trattati nello
stesso modo non abbiamo le stesse
Libertà ora pronti a ripetere con me è
successo quando faccio così è successo
oh
è successo poi la grinta l'avete
lasciata fuori dalla sala è successo a
me un altro è successo Vi voglio sentire
la grinta Eh ok io
devo pensare a come vestirmi e avrò
paura di tornare a casa da sola la sera
è successo non potrò vivere la
sessualità liberamente come la vivi tu
altrimenti Verrò catalogata fra le
cattive ragazze è successo quando andrò
a fare un colloquio di lavoro mi
chiederanno se voglio avere un figlio è
successo
Se sarò determinata mi diranno che sono
una donna con le palle è successo che
poi chi vi abbia detto che ci interessi
avere le palle ancora non l'ho capito ma
questo è un altro discorso
Se però sarò aggressiva nel difendere i
miei diritti mi diranno che ho il ciclo
sono una pazza isterica oppure che mi
dovrei fare una bella scopata
censuro Ma è successo guadagnerò di meno
a parità di mansioni e avrò Meno
possibilità di far carriera è successo
quando le rughe solcheranno il mio viso
io diventerò una vecchia carampana e tu
sarai
affascinante Eh no non è successo Non ci
provate ancora E quando succederà Spero
che le donne siano libere anche di
invecchiare
ma mi rendevo conto
[Applauso]
mi rendevo anche conto però degli
stereotipi tossici che intrappolano gli
uomini fin da piccoli Gli uomini non
possono piangere non possono essere
fragili altrimenti sono delle femminucce
proprio la cancelliamo questa parola qua
altra storia personale mio figlio
Leonardo aveva un anno aveva fatto il
vaccino ed era stato molto coraggioso
gli dico amore Ti sei veramente meritato
un premio
mamma vorrei un passeggino di quello per
le bambole bambole
Ma come un passeggino con tutti i giochi
che ci sono macchinine robot che
piacciono tanto a mamma un passeggino
poi mi sono fermato ho detto vabbè ma
proprio tu Gli leghi un passeggino E
cosa gli dici amore una cosa da femmine
e quindi abbiamo comprato un passeggino
e adesso ci gioca anche mia figlia
Beatrice gli amici le amiche tutti
insieme gender free Ma se noi come
genitori stiamo cercando di liberare gli
individui la battaglia è impari perché
là fuori c'è il mondo
riprendiamo la nostra piramide della
cultura dello stupro e arriviamo in cima
uccidere
per capire che cosa determini la scia di
donne uccise per il solo fatto di essere
donne perché questo significa
femminicidio per scatti g24 ha lavorato
alla campagna che abbiamo chiamato basta
sono emerse una serie di costanti il
criminale forma la propria identità su
una relazione di dominio e controllo che
con il tempo peggiora è un'escalation
senza ritorno non si tratta mai di un
raptus è una parola che dovremmo
Cancellare dal nostro vocabolario quando
parliamo di femminicidio
l'altra costante è che le donne vivono
in solitudine la violenza la commissione
parlamentare contro il femminicidio ci
dice che delle 211 donne uccise fra il
2017 e il 2018 sono gli anni con le
sentenze passate in giudicato
solo il 15 per cento delle donne aveva
denunciato il 15 per cento
le donne non denunciano perché sanno che
non verranno credute e anche quando
saranno credute verranno comunque
giudicate hanno paura della reazione
dell'uomo hanno paura di perdere i figli
della loro incolumità spesso non hanno
neppure un posto dove andare perché non
hanno un lavoro l'Istat ci dice che oggi
una donna su due è fuori dal mercato del
lavoro
se vogliamo riempire di significato
le parole libertà e uguaglianza dobbiamo
usarne un'altra
Indipendenza
a partire da quelle economica
grazie al mio lavoro ho potuto toccare
con mano che laddove si investe sulle
donne le comunità rinascono Questa
dovrebbe essere la priorità non il
controllo del corpo della donna dare
forza economica alle donne dare loro
Indipendenza per dare una speranza al
nostro paese
e invece
e invece per le donne le cose sono
ulteriormente peggiorate a causa della
pandemia perché siamo
prevalentemente impegnate in mansioni
meno specializzate e questo è dovuto un
altro stereotipo
pericolosissimo E peraltro assolutamente
infondato Quello che le donne siano meno
portate per natura per le materie
tecnico scientifiche
se vogliamo scrivere il nostro futuro
dobbiamo declinare queste parole al
femminile ricercatrice scienziata
programmatrice ingegneria perché se non
avremo queste competenze saremo
nuovamente tagliate fuori dalla storia
per farvi però visualizzare
come la cultura della violenza contro le
donne
condizioni il nostro modo anche di
leggere i fatti di vedere le cose di
pensare Vi mostro alcuni titoli di
quotidiani su femminicidi più o meno
recenti
molto geloso come ha fatto lei a non
corrispondere il gigante buono e lui
respinto le ha sparato
la vittima Chi è il povero gigante buono
il povero uomo geloso il carnefice la
donna che
se l'è cercata se l'è cercata
però mi soffermo sull'ultimo titolo
perché ci porta dentro le aule di
tribunale
è una delle sentenze più discusse della
storia giudiziaria italiana
l'imputato ha visto la sua pena
dimezzarsi in appello perché i giudici
hanno riconosciuto la gelosia
all'emotività il raptus come
giustificazione attenuante non un
aggravante Come accade in tutti gli
altri omicidi sempre la commissione
parlamentare contro il femminicidio ci
dice che nel
97% dei Tribunali non c'è la competenza
adeguata per leggere il fenomeno della
violenza in famiglia che viene nella
maggior parte dei casi derubricata a
conflitto ma sono due cose diverse
perché il conflitto presume una
relazione paritaria la violenza di
prevaricazione conflitto violenza una
questione di parola di parole che però
ha determinato la differenza fra la vita
e la morte di centinaia di donne nel
nostro paese
chiudo
da dove abbiamo iniziato la donna sola
con la minigonna
la maglietta scollata
la prossima volta
fermiamoci prima
Proviamo a non giudicare lei è lui che
ha stuprato Anche se lei indossava la
minigonna anche se lei aveva bevuto
magari era drogata è lui che ha stuprato
è lui che ha ucciso anche se lei lo
voleva lasciare anche se lo aveva
respinto anche se aveva un altro magari
altri 10
è lui che ha ucciso
è un esercizio difficile lo so
ma è iniziando a dire basta alle parole
che normalizzano la violenza contro le
donne a partire da quel se l'è cercata
che si possono salvare vite Le parole
sono armi forse le armi più potenti che
abbiamo e uso la parola armi Non a caso
è una battaglia quella che stiamo
combattendo È una battaglia per
l'indipendenza per l'uguaglianza per la
Libertà
le parole sono l'inizio di un percorso
un percorso verso un mondo più uguale
perché un mondo più uguale È un mondo
migliore per tutti
vieni Abbracciami
[Applauso]
con piacere ma era per indicarti e per
Insomma veramente particolare
per farti prendere l'applauso oltre a
quelli a scena aperta che ci hanno
veramente emozionato perché tu ci hai
emozionato
[Applauso]
Praticamente sono stati
10 anni di psicoterapia in pochi minuti
Comunque vabbè io devo ringraziare voi
non si è portato su montagne russe
emotive e ti ringraziamo davvero per una
condivisione così insomma personale
perché è qualcosa di prezioso è qualcosa
che ci porta anche a mio avviso verso
l'empatia verso quei valori delle etica
e quello energia con cui hai poi
raccontato tutte queste cose ci portano
a riflettere su un'empatia che
possiamo sappiamo di poter avere ma non
sempre si accende c'è bisogno di queste
parole di parole a me è venuto da
pensare che Noi maschi siamo almeno
figli
poi in alcuni casi siamo fratelli siamo
compagni siamo padri
quindi l'empatia potrebbe essere anche
un esercizio di
confronto con se stessi con le proprie
Insomma nei confronti delle donne che
abbiamo più vicine perché ci possono
ricordare sempre meglio tutto il resto
tu
agli uomini hai già detto tante cose
però agli uomini rispetto a questo
percorso che cosa poi aggiunge Cosa
posso aggiungere posso aggiungere che la
storia che ho raccontato È soltanto una
piccola parte mi piacerebbe dirvi che è
stata l'unica violenza che che ho
vissuto ma non è così ma penso Paolo che
se ognuna di noi qua in questa sala
potesse scrivere una cosa potremmo fare
un after party che dura fino a Natale
probabilmente e
partendo dalle parole veramente provando
a fare Questo esercizio cercando di
smettere di
pensare che noi donne siamo degli esseri
inanimati che che non abbiamo sentimenti
che non abbiamo diritto alla nostra
libertà che veramente si possono salvare
delle vite e si possono liberare le
energie delle donne quindi veramente
dare la possibilità so che tutti tutti
quelli coloro che sono qui sono padri
Fratelli Figli
ma anche coloro che uccidono non sono
alieni calati da qualche altro pianeta
lontano sono compagni e sono fidanzati e
sono mariti sono padri sono fratelli e
sono figli e quindi ecco anche qui Noi
abbiamo un dovere morale ed è anche il
motivo per cui ho raccontato questa
storia di non far sentire solo le
persone e di aprire gli occhi tutti
quanti noi possiamo essere testimoni di
una violenza in questo momento non
facciamo finta che quella cosa non ci
riguardi Apriamo gli occhi è difficile
magari Inter una violenza perché il
ciclo della violenza è è perverso passa
da un momento in cui c'è una violenza
che può essere soltanto
verbale soltanto psicologica e poi c'è
il momento invece della luna di miele in
cui la donna pensa Cavolo questa volta
dai ce la posso fare a salvarlo ce la
posso fare a cambiarlo e poi dopo invece
si ricomincia e in un circuito che è
sempre che si avvita diventa sempre
più violento noi possiamo essere
testimoni Possiamo vederlo possiamo
aiutare le donne che capiamo vivere
quella violenza e non fare finta che
quella cosa non ci appartenga perché
abbiamo una responsabilità morale tutti
quanti noi Grazie assolutamente
[Applauso]
Accompagnarti e ringraziarti ancora